you remember when you were younger you
were poor and you had nothing and guess
what you still probably even think about
that as the good old days in the future
today we might be in the good old days
so let's say you're in traffic if you're
not in traffic normally and then you're
in traffic it's terrible but if every
time you got in the car from here until
the day you die there was always traffic
what would happen you would just get
used to it and so you become a veteran
this is just how it always is and so if
your mind can mentally weather itself to
get to that point then it means you can
apply that same frame to this moment
that's inconvenient I had this shirt
that I liked a lot and my cleaning
person like messed it up you just shrunk
too much that's all it was and I was
like well if every time I washed a shirt
it always had this level of shrinking I
was like would I really care I was like
well no I guess not okay and that was it
give it a shot if you're like really
stressing about stuff